what was unique about his personality  like you know for somebody to say you  know from washing windows to doing this  and you know if you got a headache  here's how to get rid of a headache and  you hit your you know you kind of  gradually go through this and I've if  you're going through this party you're  going everything had a system to it on  on what he wrote about and how many phds  he had and how many degrees he had and  the controversy behind the degrees that  he had we didn't have any what I mean  there is two stories you hear about you  hear about the amount he has and you  hear about he had none but but the truth  is he had none he flunked out of George  Washington University he did not finish  um there okay you ask about haban habad  was a larger than life character a  storyteller  if there is one word I would use to  describe Hubbard it's storyteller  [ __ ] that could be another one but  Storyteller is the more sort of  appropriate